in your book jim you kind of give us a
glimpse of your house
because when i was reading it the book
jim carrey
he buys charlie chaplin's cane for a
ridiculous amount of money
yeah but did the real gym carry by
charlie chaplin's cane
well i can tell you i can show you right
now you want to see yeah i want to see
it
okay okay all right there you go
he's walking away this is actually
it's thinner than i thought it would be
i thought it came would be much thicker
and
insignificant and he made the world with
this thing
it's incredible right where were you
when you bought charlie chaplin's cane
how did you you said you bought it with
your batman forever money
yeah but it was a it was a it was a
phone auction i heard it was available
so it was on the phone oh it's one of
those i was the
the rich uh guy in the in the booth
upstairs
is that really true like in other words
were you on that oh i have no idea i
have no idea all i know is i got it i
was like oh my god it's fantastic you
can see
in here in the inside here you can see
the worn
you know kind of aged hand marks and
things like that so it's kind of nice
i'm not a big collector you know but i
but i do value this a great deal and i
also have one of his cameras
uh from uh that shot the gold rush so
it's pretty cool
it makes sense to me that you would buy
charlie chaplin's cane because your
whole career even when you were a
stand-up
the the way you could manipulate your
face
the the choices you made in ace ventura
even going back all the way then and you
know just you know talking with your ass
cheeks i mean that [ __ ] could have
backfired on you you know
all of that could have just it could
have buried you you know but you
you took some chance we were taking
every day
every day we went and saw the dailies
and tom and i would sit back and just
howl with laughter and go it's it's the
end
if it doesn't work it's the end it's the
very end of me
you